Uh,
I was thinking about a story when I was a kid, this was the,
this is how you know, I'm down, dude. I'm down for my homeys.
And this is how you know, I'm down for my homeys is because
when I was boy, I must've been in fifth grade,
a kid came in to class
and it was a new student. We had a new student when I was in fifth grade.
His name was Thomas. That's all I remember. I don't remember his last name.
Didn't call himself, Tom. And name was Thomas.
And he was the kind of guy who looked like he should be graduating college.
You know how sometimes the kid is just like, there's a kid in your school,
in your class and you're in fifth grade and he just looks like one of the kids'
dads, he was wirey and tall was this black dude.
Nice looking, you know, Thomas
me,
I always be pre-funded the new people because I wanted to learn all about them
because let's face it. The everyday was mundane to.
So I started talking to Mo uh, Thomas Thomas turns out,
had so many penthouses and Playboys and.
And I didn't know why when I was fifth, when I was in fifth grade, I thought,
Oh, this guy must just have a up parents. Right.
Because how does he get access to this?
But he'd come and he'd bring the pieces of the pieces of paper from
penthouse. And it was the first time I ever saw like, you know,
and I seen before, but like I saw girls like fingering themselves and stuff
on never get a Disney movie. And so, um,
I saw him doing that or I saw him giving out the things and,
and he was giving, he gave one to me and I was like, Whoa.
And I remember feeling like, wow, this looks weird, but I like it.
But also it's weird. Cause you know, those girls, they didn't look natural.
They had really big boobs and their look like fried butterflies and their hair
was all teased out. Like I've never seen girls like that. You know?
And this was even in New Jersey when the girl's hairs in the eighties were nutso
teachers and. Anyway, uh, I was like, Whoa man. And he was like, yeah,
he's like, I got more where that came from. And I was like, really?
And he was like, you want me to bring them? And I was like, yup. He's like, Oh,
I gotta do is bring my, is give me your snacks tomorrow. And I was like,
cool. Okay.
So the next day I was like, Hey dad, can I get extra potato skins in my thing,
we had the little planter, peanut potato skins, things that we used to have.
I used to get, I don't know if they still exist anymore. Uh, and, uh,
and uh, and I came and it gave me more
more, more nudes. Uh, and I would, and I would,
and I would give him a potato skins and it would go down like a drug deal. Dude.
I just give it, I just slide over the things.
And I need to get high, to get older some big time.
I would slide the over there. He would give me the, yo,
we need to pump up the volume and this show will be playing in the back back.
You know what I mean?
And I can't play it or we'll get copyright infringement probably already got
with it. But anyway, um, I will be sending,
I w I would give him the and he would give me the.
And then I go into the bathroom and I'd open up the magazines and I'd see it.
And I would see new and new. And it was awesome, dude.
And this is the time where I realized, I guess I'm straight.
I didn't know about gay, but you know, if I had, I would have been like, can,
I guess I'm straight. So I really liked it. And when I got home,
I didn't want to keep it in the house. You know,
like when I watched breaking bad and when Walter White is putting the money in
the air vent, I'm like, bro, I would have found that in two seconds. Well luck.
Luckily outside of my backyard down a little bit, there was a park,
it was called Ghana called Brooke park.
And I went with my friend matcher venting,
and we took these photos of these girls post-season.
And we went way back to the other end of the park and we would bury
them.
We would bury these pictures of and in baseball card collector,
uh, holder things. Okay.
And we buried them in a canopy that you would stack baseball cards in and we put
something over it. So we could always go back to in a court,
Brooke park and get into that can and look at those. And we didn't,
we didn't even get, I don't even know if we got back then, you know,
but we were just like, we would just open it up. Like it was treasure.
It felt cool, dude. And sometimes I would go over there,
just rolling on my dolo and go look at,
put them back in the thing and go back and eat dinner with my family.
And nobody knew, dude. And it was.
The mixer. Now the rap pop, it was dope.
Dude, I felt good. And I felt sneaky. I felt like, you know,
like I had some going on and with this lasted for about a week or two
and my dad said one day,
Hey Chris, um,
come into my office. And I said, okay,
which was weird. He never did that. I went into his office and he says,
um, Hey, is there a, um,
a kid at school that's giving you nudes,
like pictures of naked women. And I said,
yeah, that's the kind of guy I am when I'm caught.
I tell you what's up, that's it. I let the cards fall as they may.
And he says, um, okay, uh,
what are the pictures of? And I explained, plus he's in and stuff.
Although I didn't say it like that when I was in fifth grade,
I just naked women. And he said, okay. He said, uh,
I want to know what these pictures are. Can you show me? And I said,
um, okay.
So I went to Yanika Brook park and rolling on my dolo,
grabbed the things, went back up to the, um, dad's office,
threw the pictures up on the thing. And I said, Hey, there are there like this.
And he saw him and he said, okay, cool. That's all. And I said, really,
am I in trouble? And he said, no. And I said, okay. He said,
but you shouldn't be doing that stuff at school or whatever. And I said, okay,
cool. And then, uh, I felt weird.
I left the room. Didn't know how he knew it.
And then a few days later he said to me, um, you know, uh,
I said, how did you find out about that? And he said, you know,
I've found out another dude who lived on the opposite.
End of aganda codebook park, who was just a, rat. You know what I mean?
A rat, like a piece of. Like his face was,
he was one of those kids who had faces that were like,
it was like pink and weird areas. You know, I'm talking about like, you know,
and he was younger than me, by the way,
a rat younger than me in like fourth or third grade.
And he had the pink like that eczema. I don't really know what the it is.
It's not eczema, but it's just like,
it's like a high C it's like leftover high C on his face. Just a dirt,
rat. And he said, I got a doorbell.
He knocked on my, on the, he hit the doorbell and it was him good.
Never came over. And he said, Hey, Mr. Dalea. I said, yeah. And he said, uh,
I want you to know that Chris and Matt [inaudible],
uh, are hiding dirty pictures, uh, outside the back of Yanacocha pro park,
near my house.
And my dad said, Oh yeah. And he said, yeah.
And then my dad said, he looked at this rat and said,
so, and the rat said, Oh,
I just thought you should know that, you know, cause they're naked.
And my dad said again, so what? And he said, Oh, okay.
And he turned around and my dad said, do you know why I said that, that way?
I said why? He said, because he was trying to get you in trouble
and I didn't want to let him have the satisfaction of it.
So I acted like it wasn't a big deal. So he felt stupid.
And I learned that then.
And that's how I know now to be down as to your family,
that one thing that happened definitely stuck with me forever.
And that rat four fourth grader die, slow.
My dad taught me a lesson. And then I said, well, why you want to see the pics?
He said, well, honestly,
the only reason why I just wanted to see the pig is why I want to make sure they
were okay.
And just if they could women and they weren't doing like weird stuff with
animals or some, and I was like, Oh yeah, that makes sense.
I love my dad. That's so dope. I can't wait to be on my kid's side.
I mean, I am now, but like, I can't wait for that to happen. And some go down.
And for me to look at some other kid that's trying to rat out of my rat. my, my,
my, my, my son, and have him be like, and I may be like,
so man, I learned, I learned that day. That was cool.
And also turns out. I like the and too. So,
um, anyway, I guess that dude, I forgot about that story.
And I wanted to tell you on the podcast because I thought it was cool,
but you gotta be down as to your family, man. You gotta be down as.
Um, thanks guys. Look, it's a little weird doing this podcast all alone.
I gotta be honest. Um, I'm trying to do my, my right.
And be good by everyone and not be out and stay in my house alone, uh,
doing this podcast and not have one fire or, um, uh,
I've been getting rid of over here.
So we're not coughing on each other who knows,
but I'm doing this social distancing and I'm taking it seriously and you should
too men. And if you live in Florida and if you're going to beat the beaches and,
you're, you're a straight up piece of.